pardon me once to like knock down is his
long-distance relationship which isn't
even real but you know we won't go there
that's fine it's it's totally fine to
fulfilled and my phone I thought he was
gonna take the pants off she's real I
know she's real but like yeah I have a
girlfriend in Canada - it's cool - ah a
single life what a thrill out there on
your own
unattached untethered drifting floating
further and further alone
you know maybe relationships aren't so
bad after all or maybe they're a drag
hey I don't know it's debatable
I'm single and happy I am Perl
relationship and I for the single life I
mean there are relationship and thrills
I am for being being in a relationship
is fantastic I am down for relationships
I am crazy
being single is [ __ ] awesome excuse
me I just had a cough
go ahead you're not happy really
scientifically until you're kind of you
know get to know yourself and you can't
get to know yourself when you're
constantly on someone else telling you
what they want and what they like all
the time you don't need another person
to make you happy okay you just need
yourself but I love that like early
stage of a relationship when you're not
sure what you're like what you are to
each other and that's why it's exciting
because when you go to places you're
just like on the prowl you have like
this mission your mission isn't to be
there in the thing that you're doing so
you try to say every time I go out I'm
just looking to [ __ ] because you're kind
of right it's not about sleeping with
somebody it's having a loving committed
relationship with somebody that you can
better I mean then if it's not about
sleeping with someone then I don't know
what were you been talking about it's
like watch TV in bed eat food in bed
don't have to worry about looking good I
eat worse when I'm in a relationship
because I go out all the time and I'm
happy when I'm depressed and lonely I'm
like think I'll have this salad for a
while I'm worrying about if someone's
happy or fed or breathing it's like you
worry about take care of you worry about
your friends or your mother or your dog
or like that kind of thing my dogs dead
you have to ask permission for anything
I never asked for permission I don't
know what relationships you've been in
mom is not like that at all there's more
money involved when you're in a
relationship you gotta buy two of
everything
two plane tickets two dinners two pairs
it's true if the alternative is just
never doing anything eating I think
there's one of the better parts to
relationship you know like Chris Rock
playing like our relationship is just
[ __ ] and eating and sleeping and that
sounds like a good thing that sounds
pretty great actually
right if she were to leave you would
have a giant chunk missing from you you
are not a complete person without her
which to me means you are not a fully
formed person if and therefore are
thrown to a lot of vulnerabilities
I'm not probably any vulnerabilities
what happens if she leaves Steven
relationships only go two ways you get
married or you break up so you've chosen
someone you get along with someone that
you can laugh with like a friend like a
friend like a friend I'm talking about
like the time you spend together is
valuable and good and like that's what
you're getting out of it you're not just
getting like Oh on my tombstone it can
say that I was with somebody when I died
that's not what you're doing born alone
and we all die alone in the end right
everybody has a bad like ugly side when
you're a relationship you only show it
to that person they're like a sponge for
your awfulness sometimes so you don't
show it to the rest of the world and not
that she completes me it's that we
together aren't a whole nother level
where you're like down here just like
feeling around with yourself literally I
mean you will income no kids see that I
can get on board with yeah that's that's
called being in a boss ass relationship
everything is half hot you buy a TV you
split the TV when you buy a bed you can
split it and you have meals you can try
different items but when you're not in a
relationship and you're going on lots of
dates tons of stuff free you talking
about how you love yourself you're so
rich you're still you're so cool with
not cheating with other people they're
not a team players what you are you
should go
fight your own business and do your own
thing what are you doing here at
BuzzFeed your whole series is single as
[ __ ] because you can't even get a
girlfriend yeah what would your
seriously called Steven boring ass [ __ ]
boom been waiting for that one you're
like you're like we're doing this and
we're so good at it like weren't year
four and you kind of get like a second
honeymoon because you're just so proud
of yourselves
in it [ __ ] then it gets hard it does
get hard it gets hard and then it ends
because or it never ends and you're
together forever oh my god really
there's just not enough fish in the sea
and I know that argument is oh well but
really honestly I don't mean enough
people where I'm like year's greatest
mean I understand that you can be happy
that thank you but you can be happier if
you're single don't let anyone make you
feel bad about it
do you I'm out by Stephen he's great
you'd be and make a great boyfriend
actually I would have a date